30 activists from eight European countries.
We were, during two days,
the European Parliament in Strasbourg.
It was important for us to be there
because it's the last session of your confinement of this term.
We made a lot of actions during these two days.
The first one was an action with banners and with flames.
Jetzt Geht's Los.
Genau Jetzt sprechen wir einmal noch mal mit abgeordneten.
Sag ich noch mal sozusagen in einer der allerletzten sitzungen.
Dieser sitzungsperiode ist auch nicht verletzt,
was wichtig ist, weil der Green deal ist eigentlich ne gute sache
natürlich noch nicht gut genug.
Aber ähm soll fundamental Abgeschlecht Werden und äh.
Das wird in der nächsten nächste tour weitergehen.
Und deswegen machen wir jetzt noch mal klar. Ähm
jetzt sozusagen. Machen wir
was wir am besten können und zwar äh ne kleine aktion.
So, as you know,
tomorrow we're doing this whole banner drop thingy,
and there's a very strong possibility
that we would get kicked out of the yards of prominence.
So I think it's really important that, uh,
we are all, um.
That we're making up our mind,
and if we are in. In whatever role.
Yeah. We're going to have, like,
a good, proper briefing tomorrow.
It's like 10:45 or something. Yeah.
Yeah. Maybe we should leave the room. In the small room.
The
second day, we entered in the parliament
and we made also an action with banners
and we have songs, and it was very.
Was there We also, um. Uh.
We were not kicked out of the parliament,
but the security said we. We could not enter the plannery.
Nevertheless, it's, uh, uh,
total success, because we made a lot of factions
which were very visual, which was related by the press.
So, yeah, total success.
I
don't know what happened.